if you need to lose that 10 25 50 75 100
pounds or more contact young associate
and ask for the book Hell's Kitchen and
the book epigenetics the death of the
genetic 3 disease transmission and learn
how to lose a half a pound two pounds a
day a half a pound of 2 pounds a day
that's cause again the medical doctors
have it all wrong being overweight and
obese has nothing to do with lack of
exercise eating too much it's actually
simple deficiency of nutrients get a
hold of the book epigenetics and the
book oh yeah Hell's Kitchen and learn
how to lose a half a pound of 2 pounds a
day and you'll never gain the weight
back as long as you stand you're 90 for
Life program ok Doug what pearls wisdom
to have for us today
I wanted to talk a little bit about
weight loss as I've got a story here
from Reuters that his headline number of
obese and overweight children are under
5 alarming according to the World Health
Organization they said at least 41
billion children under the age of 5 are
obese or overweight across the world and
say the number of obese and overweight
children has risen by 10 million since
1990 they're now more overweight and
obese children in low and middle income
countries there are in high-income
countries in developing countries the
number of overweight children more than
doubled to 5 15.5 million in 2014 from
7.5 million in 1990 driven by
globalization and urbanization according
to the World Health Organization's
Commission on ending childhood obesity
better known as echo their co-chair
Surya dished our said overweight and
obesity impact a child's quality of life
as they face a wide range of barriers
including physical psychological and
health consequences
almost half of the overweight and obese
children under 5 live in Asia 25% live
in Africa where the number of overweight
children and it's almost doubled to ten
point three billion in 2014 from 5.4
billion in 1990 Libya Egypt Morocco
Algeria Tunisia and Botswana are the
highest percentage of overweight
children above the African countries
they say children who do
have access to enough nutritious food in
early childhood are at a particular high
risk for becoming obese and with their
food intake an activity levels change
say children of migrant and indigenous
people were also at a higher risk of
becoming obese due to rapid cultural
changes as limited access to health care
now I don't understand how limited
access to healthcare is going to affect
your amount of obesity and being
overweight weird we have a third of the
people of this country or where we're
leading the world to being overweight
and we have most access to health care
of any country on the planet so that
doesn't make any sense well it doesn't
make any sense if you're looking for
truth but if you're looking for
increasing your income from people and
you're a medical doctor you say well
anything that's going on with health we
see more doctors the problem will go
away right so that's just a sales
campaign they're taking advantage of a
situation here now the first time I went
to China was back gosh it had to be 1980
85 86 and everybody there was skinny I
mean everybody skinny there's almost no
diabetes now you go to China
50% of people in China are overweight
and obese and diabetes is breaking him
financially
because they pay for everybody's health
care well basically the problem comes
like this and same thing with Africa
when I was in Africa back in the 60s
everybody there was skinny now there's
so much obesity blows your mind so
what's going on here well Doug what
happens is as soon as a country gets
into the leading edges of being a first
world country an industrialized nation
they give up wood stoves no more wood
ashes for the gardens they go to
electricity so they don't have access to
their source of minerals and so their
appetizer up because they're merely
deficient and they all gain weight I
mean within 10 years after moving to
electricity from wood stoves number of
wood ashes in the garden more
electricity guess what they all become
overweight because they're mentally
deficient and so what we got to do is
get the word out get on the 94 live
program Alti blood sugar pack one per
100 pounds of body weight if you're on
medication take your passing pleasure
every morning before you medicate
yourself and
your blood sugar drops should take less
medication you're on you're without
medication for two weeks and your blood
sugar remains below 100 and in American
terms below five and the Canadian terms
guess what you don't need the medication
anymore but you still need to stand the
90 cents on your shins because they're
not going to be these nutrients left in
your food a week from now a month from a
year from now five years from now you
still have to supplement so it all is
the cause of lack of nutrition get a
hold of the book epigenetics and dead
doctor no lyin lose the weight